for you uh you've been a part of the
scene for so long I know a lot of you
know your personal issues aside but I
feel like a lot of the issues in Detroit
for the most part have been put to rest
and it feels as unified as I've seen it
in a while in terms of the top guys kind
of moving together but
um why do you think that is because
everyone's kind of growing up a little
or it just feels like everyone's kind of
moving in the right direction uh well
it's two things
nobody got hurt you know what I'm saying
because that's hard to come back from
yeah it wasn't no blood behind our
situation and then another thing we are
older you know what I'm saying and we do
owe that to the city because it's like
everybody wanted to see that you know we
want to see these guys come together so
bad
and it was just like time for it
so as we got older and everybody got
kids and we lost guys on our side they
lost guys on their side not from
like each other but just losing right
right it happens and it's like man we
need to put that [__] to the side
and just do this for the city and make
it look good and that's what we did and
now we actually good friends all of us
no I see it man it's dope to see and
it's dope to see like
you know a guy like yourself have to go
sit down for a little bit and then come
out and Thrive at a level higher than
you've ever thrived in your career and
on that same token a guy like I swear
Vezzo who had to do the same thing right
and and you guys it's just whenever I
talk to artists who aren't from Detroit
and I just we just talk about hip-hop's
landscape I always tell everybody like I
think right now Memphis got the got this
[__] it was hot but I do think Detroit
is on their ass Memphis if it's hot but
Detroit you can't we we in there you
know no it's like for real and and even
just like the influence and like whether
it's the production or the flows I just
feel like
yeah but listen though right
and that is true but the sound that
everybody here
is a flint song it's not even Detroit
you did what I'm saying
you might hear more of a Rio and Mike or
try to make some yeah shout out to Flint
that was one of the best funniest
interviews I've ever done shout out to
ree but the sound that like is more fast
it's more funny it's more that's really
not a Detroit sound shout out to bfv the
Pac-Man you facts that's my dude yeah
that's my dude
but the sign that y'all here like the
the funny the funny rap is like Fast
yeah no no like no choruses
that's really not a Detroit sound it's
more of a flint sign like real and Mike
in them is kind of like the four or
fives of that you know how's Rio doing
real excellent real super straight real
be home soon yeah dude do we know when
he's gonna be out no I can't even I
can't announce the date but he'll be on
soon yeah yeah that's a hell of a well
you you guys are a one-two punch man oh
man it's crazy yeah it's different like
me and bro together is millions on top
of millions
it's got to be like you get out
small period of time where you're out
and he's out and then he's got to go in
and then you that you got a hit so it's
like he probably seen that [__] from the
cell like bro bro you got one for real
like he's just sitting back and just you
know
I don't really know how to explain it
because we so used to
like
all right how can I say it because all I
want to say this in a way to hit him
I've been having records like going yeah
in the streets are like yeah you got the
two million up it feels good to me but I
didn't allow myself to get over excited
because I had already kind of like been
used to knowing how to move with these
type records you feel what I'm saying so
it kind of kept me like on a humble like
so far as re I don't really know how to
explain it like how he feel about it
right me I'm still kind of like I don't
allow myself to get too excited about it
so we allow ourselves to stay home and
keep working